it has a long thin tongue the wings of a
bat and a taste for the bloody insides
of sleeping victims so gross it's a self
segmenting vampiric female monster with
dangling intestines this thing is insane
Thank You PBS Digital Studios I'm
finally making a show about Mon and
ongal I'm dr. Emily zarqa and this is
monstrum
I've been dying to do this episode since
I first pitched this series there's
something so on and obviously disturbing
about this particular monster the modern
angle is one of many types of Oswald a
Filipino word meaning demon ghoul or
which these demonic creatures have
appeared in literature as early as 1580
to in Spanish missionary texts but
before the Spanish arrived it's very
likely that the indigenous peoples of
the Philippines already had oral
folklore about this monster the vicious
organ sucking mud and angle is sort of
like an aztlán subspecies there are many
different types of monsters in the
Philippines that are labeled as Aslan
but their appearance and habits divide
them into subcategories there's the
blood sucking vampire the mani weredog
the vindictive her evil eye which the
carrion eating ghoul and the subject of
this video the self segmenting viscera
sucker the name Mon and angle comes from
the Filipino word meaning to remove or
to separate this is what makes this
Aslan particularly unique because she
detaches her upper body from her lower
torso
she done soars across the skies at night
with that light wings but during the day
the Monon angle is such it look like a
beautiful woman she has adapted
successfully concealing her monstrous
form and maintaining normal
relationships they can even be married
her true nature is revealed at night
when her arms convert to wings her torso
divides and she flies under the cover of
darkness looking for human victims she's
known to use her long thread-like
tubular tongue to reach through an
opening in a window or roof entering
into the victim's body through the ears
nose mouth or abdomen to feed on some
pretty disgusting stuff like the
discarded phlegm from sick people or
entire livers lungs intestines and
hearts of adult victims and even fetuses
pregnant women are rumoured to be their
ideal prey like I said they are really
gross to prevent the monster from going
back to her normal human form one can
sprinkle ashes vinegar spices garlic or
salt onto her lower body stuff
which will prevent her from becoming
whole again so to conceal her identity
and seamlessly return to that of a
normal woman in the morning
the modern angle hides the lower half of
her body while she hunts this is very
important for her to do because she will
die if her upper torso cannot reattach
before daybreak banana groves are
reportedly good hiding spots
maybe because banana trunks can look
like human legs their creation story is
just as bizarre a woman is transformed
into am on an angle if she eats a baby
black chicken that has been produced
from the throat of an older existing
mountain ongal but there is one way to
cure a newly transformed man on an angle
by removing the baby chick from her
stomach before it matures supposedly
this can be done by hanging the woman
upside down from a tree and beaten and
fumigated her or by swinging her
violently until she pukes up the bird
which both to be honest also seemed
pretty horrifying if it's too late for
all that and you need to kill them on an
angle but you can't find its lower torso
to season there's always a good old
sharp bamboo spear in the back some of
the reasoning behind these attributes is
a mystery but I do have a few guesses by
naming pregnant women and unborn
children the ideal prey unexpected
complications of pregnancy even
miscarriage could be blamed on a monster
and the tubular tongue thing might have
taken some inspiration from the largest
skeeto population in the Philippines but
those are only small parts of all this
weirdness we can speculate as to why
this violent female viscera sucker
became more prevalent after Spanish
colonization of the Philippines in 1521
before the Spanish influence kinship and
inheritance were bilateral with both
male and female familial lines
recognized divorce was socially
acceptable and could be initiated by
either party somewhat
in ancient Filipino cultures also held
important roles serving as shaman
priestesses mediums and healers they'd
important duties and were involved in
many ceremonies and rituals including
presiding over ancestral offerings of
food and drink as mediums they could
predict the future by reading signs in
nature and also interpret dreams
consider the keepers of historical
knowledge they would retell the myths
that influence cultural morals women
also served as herbalist and midwives
which are valuable roles in society but
Spanish colonialism had a dramatic
effect on indigenous religious practices
and the roles of women in sexuality the
pre-colonial Filipino cultures didn't
put a particular value on chastity for
any gender although extramarital
relationships were seen as improper only
for women when the Spanish came and
promoted even enforced Christianity
non-marital sexual relationships were
increasingly discouraged and procreation
was promoted as the primary purpose for
sexuality removing sexual social and
religious power from the female
population in indigenous communities
changed how women were perceived the
midwives herbalist and shamans were
recast as witches to discredit their
influence enter the mon and angle think
about it it's a female monster who
threatens to eat fetuses among other
things it's literally an exact reversal
of the work associated with midwifery
you could even argue that the reason
these creatures detach their upper
bodies is to separate them from their
sexual organs some scholars argue that
the lingering effects of the moon and
angle include architectural elements a
fear of these monsters in rural areas
may have led to changes and how homes
were constructed including the addition
of steep pitches on the roof and
strategically placed windows to
discourage purging social habits may
have been affected too children slept in
the center of the room or between
parents to protect them from the long
tongue of the Mon and uncle another
cultural practice could have been
influenced
here this creature how balut is consumed
balloon is the Filipino term for
fertilized duck egg that is boiled and
eaten directly from the shell no one is
really sure how long balut has been
consumed in the Philippines because part
of Spanish conquest included burning the
writings of indigenous people
nevertheless there are some particular
ways of eating balut
that might be explained by the mana
dongle a 2002 study of balut eaters
revealed that although many of the
respondents enjoyed eating it they were
disgusted with the idea of eating the
embryo especially if they saw the chick
could this be why the Montand angle is
the ultimate taboo because it not only
eats children but the unborn some said
that eating Balu quote makes a person
like in Aswan also known as a mana novel
remember the modern angle and other
Aswan are said to be driven away by salt
and spices balut is commonly eaten with
pepper vinegar and chilies salt or other
spices perhaps in order to unconsciously
ward off the negativity they associate
with the monsters that prey on the
unborn I can't help but think this
connects back to how these monsters are
said to be created by swallowing a young
bird which came first the balut or the
mana novel Filipino horror movies
featuring traditional monsters
contributed to a national identity by
revitalizing traditional folklore
like Mun and angles she's been a staple
in Filipino cinema since pioneer
filmmaker Jose Nepomuceno made on Mon
and angle in 1927 we'll never know what
this first Montanan goal on film looked
like since that movie did not survive
but she does appear alongside other
Aswan in the 1932 film on Aswan and more
recently in a 2016 film
a few of the female self segmenting
viscera suckers have appeared in
Filipino popular culture
[Music]
but very few globally
these monsters are relatively unknown
outside of Southeast Asia but that might
be changing Netflix is reportedly
developing an animated series based on
the filipino comic pressing the
award-winning series follows a female
detective who solves supernatural crimes
there's even a gang war between an
Aswang clan and am on an ongoing plan
the mana non goals evolution is rooted
in the indigenous history of the
Philippines it reveals how Spanish
colonial ization forever changed their
culture
she is one of the more physically unique
monsters I've come across I think we
should be seeing more of this
stomach-churning creature so who wants
to make a horror movie super gross ha ha
ha
awesome Wong her too huh who a nun go
crash okay